hoy voy a hablar del tema que me
apasiona el que me hace sentirme viva
feliz y el que me hace ganar un
dinerillo por aquí se llama este tema es
de liderazgo y quiero hablar de
liderazgo porque sé que todos todos no
somos líderes
nada más en algunos faltó ese guía y a
lo mejor ese guía pudo haber hecho que
muchos de ustedes no tuvieran que
preguntarse si son líderes
bueno yo hago exactamente y
absolutamente nada más lo que me permite
sentirme viva libre y feliz esa es como
mi política privada y no hago nada más y
quiero hablarles del tema de liderazgo y
de dónde salió esta líder que llevo
dentro yo a los 8 años me sentaba sin
saber en un sillón y así como como lo
digo pasó y quiero contar esta historia
maravillosa que nunca he contado porque
me parece que es el momento de que sea
contada cuando tenía estos 8 años
presentaba en este sillón iba a la caja
está este cajón donde haga estas
cucharas y textual agarraba la de los
frijoles que era de madera y me sentaba
en el sillón de la sala y mi público era
el mejor público que pude haber tenido
hasta el día de hoy sin agraviar a los
presentes mi padre mi madre y mis
hermanos
mi padre siempre aunque me equivocaba él
siempre decía bravo bravo viví y vivi
párense todos aplaudirle a su hermana
porque qué bien lo hace ella es una
líder es la primera vez que yo oí la
palabra líder
en mi vida ni sabía de qué se trataba ni
sabía que me estaba imponiendo mi papá
ni sabía lo dichosa que iba a ser toda
mi vida
por ser esa líder que mi papá
hizo a través de 50 años hasta su último
respiro de vida hasta su último respiro
de vida hoy eres una gran líder
mover a las masas
y lo harás para bien
cuando tenía 27 años había un concurso
que se llamaba inter model
era en 1999 en el teatro de la ciudad de
aquí de monterrey
era pues de televisión y de radio con
gente con mucha experiencia
yo no tenía experiencia pero mi papá me
motivó y me dijo tú eres una gran líder
y vas a ganar y solamente tienes que
hablar del corazón que yo decía como no
es el que se va a subir verdad entonces
en la comida en esta comida quiero hacer
quiero remontarme en ese momento y
traerlos a esa mesa cuando mi papá dijo
si tú logras ganar ahí
enfrentarte con mucha gente que tiene
mucha capacidad experiencia
podrás lograr absolutamente todo porque
vencerás tu miedo tu ego a hacerlo mal
bueno pero si gano y qué premio me da
si ganas el primer el primer lugar
estatal te dejó ir al nacional a méxico
en ese momento
tenía otras actividades trabajaba y yo
vivía en la casa de mis papás
y él me dijo que me ayudaría
recuerdo ese día
como si fuera hoy trató de controlar mi
emoción
bajo el micrófono
soy viviana chávez aprendan se mi nombre
porque voy a trabajar en la televisión y
en la radio en méxico
eso fue
hoy emocionadísima les digo
para qué te sirve tu vida
si no puedes hacer algo
que te apasione
que te haga llorar
que te haga sentirte viva que el corazón
que te quiera salir del corazón del
pecho por algo que te gusta
porque vivir la vida siguiendo a
oficinas que no te gustan que no te
pagan lo que mereces
porque no arriesgar el todo
porque no arriesgar el todo por alcanzar
tu felicidad
esto no es fácil ni lo que haces tú es
fácil ni lo que haces tú es fácil a lo
que te invito
es que tengas está misión en tu vida que
te permita a través de todas las
adversidades
salir adelante y si tienes que empezar
una y dos y tres veces no importa
porque mientras hay vida y esperanza y
mi vida no será en vano
y respirar hasta la última
gota que tenga
para poder hacer realidad
lo que alguien vio al vi y que hoy me
permite estar en frente de todos ustedes
sin visión no hay pasión y sin pasión no
hay éxito nos enseñan a ser líderes de
bajo perfil a mí no me enseñaron a ser
líder de bajo perfil
a mí me enseñaron a ser líder punto y
hacer cosas buenas por otros esos hacen
los grandes líderes que trascienden
y todos somos líderes en nuestras áreas
y hemos sido reconocidos y nos ha
costado dar el primer paso y a veces el
primer paso no es el que más te cuesta
si no es el que mantienes el paso que
mantienes constante
tal vez te hayan dicho que es imposible
y que es imposible de lograr lo que tú
tienes en mente que nadie lo ha logrado
y que menos tú tendrás la capacidad para
hacerlo porque nadie lo ha logrado
si eso lo has oído
siento mucho que lo hayas oído en tu
núcleo de familiar en tu núcleo de
trabajo en algún lugar eso es mentira
no naciste para no hacer nada realidad y
te voy a poner un caso simple
luchaste con millones de espermatozoides
y fue fuiste el único líder
que pudo llegar
hoy eres un ser humano
ya sabías las adversidades desde ese
momento esto es pan comido
como es pan comido
sin visión no hay pasión y sin pasión no
hay éxito sí
me levanto todos los días queriendo
tener más éxito porque hago mucho
trabajo y me la parto en lo que hago y
tengo esta visión de querer cambiar el
mundo con mis experiencias con las
experiencias que me han dado otros a los
que agradezco a mis maestros
a las personas que sin quererlo una
frase en mí cambió la perspectiva de lo
que yo veía
yo veo este mundo maravilloso
un mundo que todos los días nos da la
oportunidad
para hacer las cosas bien con
experiencia porque además podemos tener
esta experiencia
me gustaría quejarme no puedo no me la
he visto tan no ha sido tan fácil mi
vida pero no tengo tiempo de quejarme
y no tengo tiempo de quejarme porque ha
sido de más bendición todos los
tropiezos que he tenido en mi vida han
sido más de bendición créanme cuando les
digo son más bendiciones cuando me dicen
que no cuando no me firman el contrato
cuando no me quieren dar el inmueble
cuando me dicen que no es posible cuando
me ponen todas las trabas del mundo
no es que sea tan feliz
pero eso me da experiencia y en lugar de
quejarme tomo esa experiencia hoy en un
mundo de pandemia
hemos perdido gente muy valiosa
gente muy valiosa que pudo darle a
nuestra forma de vida mucho valor y
aprender de sus conocimientos y de sus
experiencias de su forma tan decente y
honorable de vivir
hagamos
de esas pérdidas que no volverán
un orgullo el poder respirar el poder
vernos el poder hacer nuestros sueños
realidad sean los que sean
y si alguna vez
oíste que no se podía hoy yo te digo que
yo pude
yo pude ante muchas adversidades
y a veces
no hay que vender la desgracia para
tener el aplauso
hay que tener el aplauso sin tener que
traer esta desgracia nosotros tenemos
muchas historias que podríamos compartir
de perdidas de dolores
pero estos líderes tales como somos
nosotros
nos han enseñado otros líderes que solo
hay que ver para enfrente
y para poder ser un ejemplo de vida hay
que empezar a hacerlo por el círculo
primario que es la familia
los dejo siempre lo pedimos porque esto
me emociona mucho
desde el primer día tuve a mi público
maravilloso
el mejor
y se llama
andrés y es mi hijo sorry
te amo y te agradezco todo lo que soy en
la vida me has enseñado más de lo que
creía cuando te tome en mis brazos
te agradezco el amor y todo lo que tú y
yo hemos vivido y esto hoy yo te lo
dedico a ti
por el amor que te tengo
y por todo lo que tú me has apoyando
esta historia
espera que pase en la historia hijo
porque hay muchos más
te sientes lo mismo que yo este orgullo
del apoyo incondicional que tú me has
brindado toda la vida y si no fuera
mucho pedir les pido un aplauso para mi
hijo aquí esta es se llama andrés
y para cerrar con algo más emotivo mamás
échame la sergio échame la de chamela
esto es lo que hago cuando salgo a dar
conferencias y hablo de inspirar un
mundo mejor y dejar en ti y dejar en ti
una conciencia una palabra que pueda
generar en ti el tener misión porque si
visión como hay pasión participación no
hay éxito se levantan tantito conmigo
quieren mover un poco el cuerpo conmigo
y decirle a esta vida gracias porque nos
dejaste gracias porque hoy seguimos aquí
gracias por la oportunidad de
equivocarnos
gracias por lo que encierra y por los
que todo lo que tiene que es ser feliz
súbeme de sergio dos minutos
así se siente vivir después vivir
muchas gracias
yo les agradezco estos minutos de
compartir con ustedes y créanme
que cuando estoy nerviosa o voy a salir
al escenario
esto hago y como esto hago así me voy de
dejar lo antiguo
gracias
i